um
breaking a little bit the the topic of
this of this session because i'm i'm
speaking instead of just mean that we
couldn't make it uh because of kobit
so
this is actually
not the title that it should be it
should be the efficiency of logic at
inactivation and
and maybe this is one of the main
messages of my my talk this change on
this this work uh this is mostly the
work of uh beatrice bursary i was a
speech student in my group it's now a
postdoctorate yell and silver prince
luke who took care of the experimental
part
i'm not sure how familiar you are with a
thinking in the field of the role of
historical modifications in the
regulation of gene expression but
essentially there is this hypothesis
that stone code in which there is a role
for history modifications in the
regulation of gene expression with a
number of history modifications
positively associated with gene
expression
and the number of
modifications uh
playing a repressive role in gene
expression and
i think that for people that are outside
of the field this is more or less the
thinking you know and there is
there is a lot of evidence that this is
the case uh these are for instance
the work of martin bingron in which they
they develop methods to predict
levels of gene expression
based on levels of histone modifications
with very good accuracy
and extrapolable from one cell line to
another this is a work actually by
zipping wank here in which again she was
able to predict or the group actually i
think i am out on this paper i was able
to predict levels of gene expression
from
from history modifications with with
high accuracy
i apologize cp because i didn't warn you
that i was going to say that this is
wrong but anyway
that we were wrong anyway anyway we uh
some time ago we published this paper in
which we showed that uh there are cases
in which you get expression
without uh without uh
changing him in with the with uh without
actually the canonical uh uh history
modifications involved in gene
expression and i'm sorry i brag about
this
and this is i'm sorry that hugging is
not here because this is by by by louis
louis
is hagen's wife and and actually we had
a number of of covers inspired in in
catalan painters and you said this by by
by actually hugging shoulders what in
genome percentage as well this is also
by luisa this is by recent a paper that
we published together i back to back
with gil and this is gaussian this is
because of the person's not catalan but
doesn't really matter
this is not done by research this is
done by an artificial intelligence
program i wanted to apologize to again
because
super moving into anyway so we were not
the first or the last to actually
pinpoint that there are cases in which
we see expression with this canonical
behavior of crystal modifications before
and after so we were actually interested
in this issue is there a causal role for
history modifications in the regulation
of gene expression
and as far as i can tell
there are two ways in which you you can
assess causality if you want to know
whether a is the cause of b or actually
you want to i'm sure you can prove this
but you can't disprove
you can actually do a disruption
experiment if you disrupt a and b still
of course
clearly a cannot be the clause of b but
there is another way of doing this is
observe the two phenomena a and b during
time and if b always occur before a
a
in the world in which we live cannot be
the cause of b
so that's what we that's what we did we
took a
trans-differentiation model a simple
trans-differentiation model that turns
differentiation from b cells to
macrophages this is a
this uh
model that has been built well studied
at our institute by thomas graf so we
had the expertise and we actually
obtained
rna-seq and chipseq on
many history modifications at 12
different time points during this during
this process
i am a little bit embarrassed to use
is sick data in this meeting with
everybody is talking about signal cell
but i think i had good reasons to
say that single cell would not help at
all
to into this into this case because
there is no way in which we can study
the same cell over time right we have to
destroy the cell every time that we do
these experiments and actually this is
one of the major challenges i think in
this field that when we
discussed the other day i think that we
did not mention this but the fact that
we destroyed the cell not only has an
impact
on the cell but actually makes
impossible to study the behavior of the
cell over time
so
this process occurs with transcriptional
with massive transcriptional changes is
the translation between different
lineages so this means that
it's a great model to study to study
phenomena associated with transcription
because you see many transcriptional
changes this is an emotional cellular
system so it's not a developmental model
in which you have many many different
types this is just one cell type that
translates to another is highly
synchronized so
and actually something that we did
which i think is important is that
with it all the assays in the sample of
france differentiate cells so the
rna-seq and the chipset is not from
different experiments it's from the same
pool large pool of cells that are the
transit friendships at the same time
i think this is the causes that we can
think to uh to a single cell experiment
and then we we measure the expression
and the histone marks and it's a very
simple data type right so we have
the values of of expression
[Music]
well we have the values of expression
here for the genes and the ten points
and the values of the chromatid marks
non-chromatic bars uh time points and
genes and then we measure the of course
there's always
somebody will be genetic here we just
measure the expression and the chromatid
marks at different that sorry the
chromatin marks at different sites
around the gym body mostly at the
promoter for most of the max
and of course we could try to
recapitulate what has been published in
the field so we could compute at teach
some point in steady state the
correlation across genes right between
gene expression and chromatid marks and
indeed will recuperate what has actually
been published very high correlation for
the positively associated chromatid max
and negative associated for the marks
that are canonical canonically assumed
to be repressive
but of course now we have something
which you think is better because we
have the 12 10 points and then we can
compute the correlation
per gene across the time point so we can
compute the distance expression on the
chromatin marks and when we compute now
we have a correlation version and when
we compute the distribution of these
correlations what we observe is that the
correlation is quite substantially lower
right when we
measure over time the changes in
expression informative marking
correlation is lower than the one that
has been computed on a steady state and
actually in some cases
it's contrary to what has been
published in the field so for instance
aesthetic and anti-mediation which is
typically considered repressive mark we
see it positively associated with
expression alone time so why why is this
well we think that this is because the
correlations computed this this theme
are partially partially artifactual and
the way in which i am going to show this
is just by randomizing the association
between gene expression and and
and histone modification so this is one
gene we have the expression values
across the 12 10 points we have the
crystal modification values across the
12 10 points which is randomized so we
destroy the association absolutely and
of course when we compute the
correlation across time points the
correlation is zero right as you expect
but when we compute the correlation the
steady state on data that's randomized
we still see five very high corrosion
right verified correlation uh for
positively associated mars even though i
emphasized there is we have destroyed
all the correlation
this is because i think there are
the constrained structure of the
transcriptome so there are genes that
are always very highly expressed and
they are always really highly marked and
genes that are never expressed and never
marked and these are always the same
across all the time points and therefore
uh
they dominate the correlation but there
is this doesn't really reflect any real
association between expression and
history modification so it's not only
that correlation doesn't really
reflect calculation is actually
correlation in this case doesn't even
reflect association
so to
we have a
sort of complex uh
well simple but complex of the structure
in the sense that we have many chromatin
modifications so in order to get an idea
of how all these modifications behave
globally in relation within expression
we use this hidden markov models but
these are let me see these are not
hidden micromodes in which we partition
the genome sequence we partition the
time
right we partition the time at each at
the gene right we have a pitch
standpoint we have a set of marks that
define the chromatin state of the sheet
and what we do is we for a gene we have
a partition of the gene across the
across the 12 time points i think that i
don't need to emphasize this in the
audience but it's not obvious always
that this is conceptually different to
the typical hidden markov models that
has been used in the film which the what
is partition is the genome sequence
right here we are not producing the
genome sequence here for each gene we
have a hidden part of model that in
principle describes right the evolution
of the chromatin state across time zen
but we did fine
of course this is always very arbitrary
you could go from five to three to three
hundred states but we found that
a model with five states it's a good
compromise between interpretability and
uh complexity of the model and so
we think that most genes are in one of
these major chromatin states
which are actually defined by an
increasing uh amount of of marking by
histone modifications and abs are genes
in which there is no there is no marking
genes in which there is no marking
mostly for extrica for
monoante methylation there are genes
that are viable and marking by
positive and negative marks and then
there are genes that are active and
genes that are very strong remark
and when we compute this over the genes
and we just cluster the genes according
to the states in which they are what we
see is that although there are cases in
which you see transitions transitions
from one state to another right most
genes remain in the same state in the
same chromatin state during
transdifferentiation
even though they may be differentially
expressed right so this is the where
they are stable expressed holland or
differentially expressed so even genes
that are differentially expressed highly
differentially expressed they remain in
the same chromatin statements for
instance one case b1 in which there is a
huge increase in expression but the
chromatin
during transmission but the system
modifications remain at the same at the
same level and this is not an artifact
of the
this is not an artifact
of i know this is a very coarse
representation of the chromosomes that
if we look at gene by gene mark by mark
we do see this right so of course we see
cases in which you see
that the changes in the histone
modification over time mirror the
changes in expression but see magnesiums
in which we see similar changes in gene
expression that are actually not
reflected in changes in
histomodification so we see
many genes number of comparable genes in
which we see changes in history and gene
expression without any any associated
changes
in in in system modification and vice
versa decisions in which
we don't see changes in gene expression
and we actually see changes changes in
history modifications and actually even
for genes that have not expressed
about during the transformation which is
changes
of course this doesn't mean that there
is no association absolutely between
gene expression and and and
and histo modifications we do see that
there is a correlation even when we
computed a long time
and um
and uh
uh
actually when when when we look at the
cases in which there are changes in gene
expression and
and changes in chromatin modifications
the changes seems to tend to be
consistent it's not that we see genes
increasing expression and then
increasing in negative margins
changes are as you would expect right if
we move from if we move from
from uh
ages of low banking to high marking we
see an increase in gene expression and
when we move from
from changes of of low mark to a strong
marking to less marking we see decreases
in gene expression
okay so to try to understand
in which cases there was this
association between gene expression and
system modifications we did something
well ready to do it complicated
i just will
tell you which is the message here the
message here is that when we see a
modification in a mark
in one direction essentially we see
modifications in all the marks we don't
see one mark changing one or one type of
system modifications occurring and then
the rest not occurring we don't see a
very combinatorial behavior we see that
eastern maps behave
more or less in a consistent way all
together
therefore we could actually look at what
was the pattern of association between
between
gene expression and chromatic marking
globally and we found three major modes
of association most of the genes most of
the genes
that change expression right do not show
correlated changes of gene expression
they actually have a stable marking or
uncorrelated marketing then there is a
set of genes that show the canonical
association between gene expression and
histomodifications and actually we see a
smaller set of genes that change in
expression without without changes in
chromatic modification
and the main thing that defines
the genes
is actually
the
activated status at the beginning of
transdifferentiation
so these genes
that have positive correlation with gene
expression are things that tend not to
be activated
at the beginning of transdifferentiation
while the genes that have not that show
no correlation during during
transdifferentiation are already
activated at the beginning of the
process
so we
think that this
indicates
that maybe
histone modifications play
an important role in the activation of
gene expression
but
once the gene is already activated they
have a very secondary role in further
regulation of gene expression and then
we actually focus in a set of genes
that are specifically activated during
transdifferentiation so these are genes
that are zero that are not expressed at
the beginning of the differentiation and
are activated at some point during this
process so that we can actually know
what happens before and after in terms
of chromatin modifications and indeed in
these genes
in these genes that are activated
during transdifferentiation they are
zero when we start the process and then
they come activated we see the canonical
correlation or association between gene
expression and histone modifications and
you can see very high very high
correlations if we look at the genes
that are already set of genes that are
already activated at
the beginning of transdifferentiation we
see that the correlations are much lower
so even for instance in this case this
index has a really high increase
in gene expression
larger than this other case we see that
essentially the chromatin the histone
modifications
pattern is quite flat
because we had this time course and
because we know in these cases right
when the gene started activation we
could actually
try to see whether there was a
logic in the order in which marks were
deposited at the promoters of the genes
and that's what that's what we did but
we observed something uh
sort of unexpected so that there are
two
types of genes right in one it's in
regarding htk 27 trimethylation these
genes are
either
premarked and remain marked over the
entire process or they are never marked
so for the genes
the majority of the genes that are
unmarked by htk273 methylation
we just do something very simple which
is to look how often right one
phenomenon of a marking of one of or by
one history modification precede the
marking by
by another and by expression and we came
up with this sort of logic
so we saw that only htk for mono and
dimethylation really preceding
expression
uh that together with gene expression
we had sdk-27 acceleration and hdk9
acceleration and then after
transcription we saw it stick
for trimethylation h636 dimethylation
and it's and much later hk it's it's h4
k20 monometilation
for the cases in which the genes were
already primark by htk to the cemetery
meditation we see that they were also
essentially premarked by everything it's
on and only
htk to the similar situation and i stick
a 36 trimethylation
followed gene expression
so we look whether this
would be reciprocated in some other
model but there are very few models as
simple of this this is a developmental
model and
because it's the oriental model this is
a set of genes that are
differentiating
is a
different set of cell types that are
differentiated that
with different dynamics which makes the
data much noiser but essentially we
recomputed the same thing for the scenes
that are activated during development
house development we see
much higher regulations for the genes
that are already expressed when we start
looking at this process again suggesting
that association that association
between histone modifications the gene
expression plays a role specifically at
the moment
only at the model of
of
gene activation and in this particular
case uh interestingly from our
development the main mode is the
pre-marking by h3k27 trimethylation and
in this particular case we actually see
the same behavior by the same behavior
that we that we saw in the case of the
genes in human that will promote that
they stick it to the seventh climate
direction so that
http follows expression
so
what what happens at the answers right
so
we
see that this is the behavior the
relationship between gene expression and
and and history modifications at um
at uh at the promoters what happens at
the at the at the enhancer so we look at
we look at two types of let's say
enhancer we just look at the region
that's upstream of the of the
of the
of the promoter and then we'll look at
abc uh and look at the promoter pairs
that were between between
five kilowatts
away and what
we saw uh so this is
this is the correlation between gene
expression and histone modifications at
the promoters the the data that i have
shown you so far
this right and the promoters this is the
digital enhancer this is the proximal
enhancers and there
enhancers is and we differentiate the
genes
that are activated during drugs
differentiation for most cases there is
a
broad epigenetic environment right of of
marking by these marks which actually is
not present in the scenes that are
that are
already already activated during
transdifferentiation which i think
further supports the idea that this
histo modifications play in a specific
role
in
in the act in the initial activation
machines
so
what we see is that
commodity markets are enhanced as
follows market card promoters so this is
the this is the time distance between
marking the generation at the promoters
that i have showed you so far
so only htk4 born on the methylation
precepts in expression the other marks
either of course follows an expression
unlikely to be the cause of gene
expression when we look at the
proximal and this top promoters will see
even a larger delay between gene
expression of marking right essentially
gene expression
iso remarking
follows marking at the enhancer at
enhancers follows follows activation of
of gene expression
and i think that we can see it
more clear here
so this is so this is uh i'll show you
what happens during these 12 time points
so these are the genes that are not
expressed
at zero hours right these are the genes
that are not expressed all these genes
will become activated during trans
differentiation and different time
points of differentiation right all the
genes most of these genes are premarked
but basically for mono and demodulation
this is the set of genes that are also
premarked but hck 27 emissions they are
very
really there is very little marking in
the genes before they are activated okay
now
all right so now we see that the genes
became activated and after the genes
became activated is when we see the
marking and
marking is much more abundant in the
promoters than enhances and advances
further delay than the promoters so the
genes are being spread at the end we'll
see all the genes expressed and the
marking
following on time
for most marks the marking at the at the
promoters
so
and include uh my last slide so
the
the association that we see right
because we see this association between
marking that enhancers and an expression
it's mostly variated actually by marking
at the promoters
so let me show you this case so this is
the correlation of expression between uh
foreign an expression at the promoter
right this is very high
when we this is then we compute the
partial correlations right
condition to the expression uh to the
marking at the different types of
enhancers and we see that the
correlation remains the same
when we compute the correlation at the
between the enhancers and the expression
right for the digital enhancers and
property enhancers we should be very
high values but we condition
on the marking of the promoters we see a
drop
in the correlation right indicating that
in general for this mark for this mark
for this mark for this mark right the
the association between
marking and enhancers and gene
expression is mediated by marking that
promoters maybe not
for history
for
monometiculation which there may be some
causal role for the marking kit that
enhances in the asian expression anyway
so these are the conclusions the
conclusions of this so the available
association between gene expression and
property marketing is weekly and
presumably reported there are a limited
number of missions from maternal states
i think this goes a little bit on this
area of the histone code in which
specific pattern of system modifications
will define right the specific
transcriptional program temporal or
special for each particular gene
the strong association between
histomodification to gene expression
it's of course only at the time of
initial activation
and a time of gene activation there is a
preferential order of marking and only a
stricken hormone when the mutilation
precedes in expression which doesn't
really mean that they have a cultural
role in real expression but these other
marks right either occur with or follows
inactivation and therefore they cannot
play a role in the regulation of gene
expression
and
marky getting answers
follows marking out promoters and it is
not directly associated associated with
gene expression
so
this is uh the acknowledgements this is
the work mostly as i said silvia perez
and vetted for charity but also the
people in my group basilis who is here
and i forgot to say before
before your tweets that the data is all
available through the encode portal
and
i'll stop here thanks
um if i may
ask a question first
and then i will pass it so
this is very interesting work and i was
wondering uh to which extent
you think that's the conclusions that
you have are related to the time frame
in which your measurements have been
done right because i mean at the end of
the day i don't know how many hours you
had but
uh
you know it's like a limited system and
uh you know to change the chromatic
states maybe you need more time
uh it is true but uh if you are totally
right so we are taking uh in some cases
this is uh days i think right
initially there are this there is a
higher time resolution
but in any case if we see something
happening
after
right uh
i don't think it is really
very
i mean the thing so we are not so we
cannot demonstrate causality but we can
disprove causality right that's the
thing i'm not saying that we are showing
that expression is the cause of the
markings but what we are saying is that
we see that this march occurs after an
expression we don't see it before gene
expression of course it could occur we
measure at 12 hours
we don't see it in nine hours it could
be 10 11 or 12 but still we don't see it
of course
i mean it could be an issue of detection
right it could be an issue of detection
it could be that we cannot discard this
that uh we don't see the mark at nine
hours we see that the scene gets
expressed at nine hours well this is not
a good plot so i don't know for instance
uh one of these cases that i show here
yeah
i don't know we may not see the marking
here
because we don't have enough
resolution with our chipset assay right
this this is a possibility that cannot
be it cannot be ruled out but in general
we don't see something preceding
expression for most of the max
but yes of course having single cell
resolution in which you could follow the
stem cell across time and measuring
expression and histomodifications
without destroying the cell and
essential that would be great right
thank you very much so
you've essentially you're essentially
taking apart the directed graphical
model we've had in our head for how
these things uh react to each other in
our causal and essentially
what i'm interested and what i'm
thinking about now is okay there are now
these hidden
variables if you will or you know who
what is there is another
um
you know object in there that is causal
potentially but not in the direct
relationship we assumed
so what what are your hypotheses about
what's your expression
i would say i would say that yeah i
don't know for i don't know really i
don't know for uh
let me say i probably would say that uh
transcription factors play a larger role
in the regulation activation on the
regulation of gene expression than
histone modifications
i think that they there is a so this one
thing right
so a histone a given histone can be
modified only once
right so a nucleosome it has two pistons
can be modified
only twice so i'm we're looking at the
window of 2000 bases there are maybe 10
nucleotides
this is not lighting expression that you
have the gene that can be transcribed
maybe one or one thousand times here
this is sort of quite a discrete
number of values right from say 10
nucleosomes from from 1
to 20 that's the maximum thing so once
i have the 20
modifications producing the
promoter of a gene i cannot
do any more modification there is not
the capacity so this is this is there is
a there is a
maximum threshold that can occur
therefore i i think it's
expected that there cannot be a linear
relationship between custom system
and gene expression because
in a give for a given gene right you
have this from 0 to 20 that's the
maximum that can change
so
now
whether
the marks that we see after gene after
gene activation are a consequence of of
uh of expression or not this i agree
with you i don't know there is a causal
link that we we don't
we don't know i don't know
audience very nice work uh so
you know that
we have a work showing that
there is no changes in in transcription
level
however there is a change in alternative
splicing meaning
you have several marks of gene bodies in
which you didn't found correlation
nevertheless it's most likely that there
are changes
in the level of of
alternative splicing especially
h3k36 trimethylation
which was never been published to be a
regulator of alternative splicing
i actually have to embarrassingly answer
you that we have to look to
splicing during this process i think
that this data is the perfect data to
look at this
we started this project
thinking on this because of splicing
but
because i think that the thing of
expression maybe is more striking
related to what the people in the field
or outside the field think we've fast
focused so far on on on expression basil
is here i don't know what either
is here uh one of the ideas that
actually we could look at this data uh
for example what you said so phil is
here and he got the work showing that
there are several markers yeah we could
look at this i'm happy to talk to you
and maybe we could do something together
because i think it's really a unique
data set in which you have this
all mars and you will have deep
paranasic so splashing can be well
characterized
yeah very interesting so do you think
this has implications for the you know
the correlations we observe in ataxic
and like chromatin accessible in general
and expression so there especially what
you are saying about
enhancers how uh you know they are
essentially prime mediated by promoters
can you tell us a little bit about that
yeah i i think that this is a really
good point we did not generate a taxi
for this uh unfortunately for this
process but i believe that the group of
thomas rap now has generated taxi and i
think that we should look
into this now really i think that this
is really because in principle here we
would expect
uh some attack
signal on the on the on the promoters of
the genes that are that are activated i
think
okay um
i was an option on this paper as well
in your paper okay okay sorry
would you care later but i have a
question about enhancers so do you are
you concluding the the marks
on enhancers
um
are now causal
okay
[Music]
at the promoters and marking a federal
motors of course after gene expression
so where i have this thing here here uh
i'm not saying that enhancers are not
important and i'm saying that markings
the marks cannot be caused because they
occurred later well
this is it
this is the proximal enhancers that
probably there are not enhancements this
is the difference this is gene
activation and this after or before
so of course we see cases in which we
see i'm marking before but in general on
average the normal the the average
behavior is that the marking at the
at the proximal enhancers occurs after
activation and the digital enhancers
here additional enhancers here you may
see some anticipation at less
than the promoters
so marking at the promoter supports
first and then at the enhancers that's
what we see on this model with the
caveat of the time resolution that we
have
done actually printed out that in this
case maybe
maybe important
okay
that's very surprising but we should
talk about this
so i was wondering more about the
regulatory program so have you look into
how it changes like uh that's like
so you see the change of the gene across
the time points but i was wondering if
there are some genes that are
activated before that belongs
transcription factors that could explain
like all the chain of activation maybe
pioneer factors and then maybe going a
bit more into
who's regulating who and maybe that's
why the enhancers are activated later
so this is the overall i didn't mention
this right this is the overall goal of
the the data set because
uh and again i'm putting too much
pressure on bacillus
[Music]
we have generated here
yes so yes so we have we have different
types of rna so on the nucleus cytosol
we have proteomics data so the overall
aim of this project is to use this data
to be able to predict the status of the
cell
at a particular time point uh taking
into account the status of the the
periods and the previous standpoint so
whether we are able to explain the
dynamics predict the expression of all
the genes to read the expression of all
the genes
based on the epigenetic
factors the transcription factor data
because we have the proteomics although
transcription factors would not be well
represented and i think although i have
to say and that's something that
i'm sorry but if you just
take time point that you predict
expression of a gene just by copying the
expression the previous time point you
will already get very good predictions
because many things don't change
expression
okay so let's thanks all the speakers of
this first session in the morning and
we'll have a break for
now
coming back at
11.